на ринку капіталу у росіян і не просто
рано мою брошкою краї намазати косого
ти один за одним auctions облігацій
від іноземні інвестори нині
налагоджувати цього ти груші в 1 годину
інвестори активно здійснюються
Адже російських акцій почала руку в
витрати московської біржі та склади 17
сотки
увігнутість ми помітив ще страх бере
санкціями може бути вона сильним
не самі санкції за прогнозами
міжнародного валютного фонду позбавити
його руку з Росії може бути розібрана
блиску 100 мільярдів доларів україна
стала пардо в гостру завантаження рецесії
рубль малий в артист і на не
товари чи стою ти дарина доріжкам і
санкції лиж і посилати тенденцію do-
знаєте мене вона багата на росіян восени
свою ситуацію немає на таку ж плану
знаєте їсти така посла я так і при
сливі я тягну нас не забуваючи
робот нас найсильнішими правити а їх
відчувається appears skoda перешкоди
стільки року висловитись я натру боюся у
нас сагу до добра
на те є багатого експерти на заході
поважають що російські проблеми щодо
в'язання не ляша з санкціями кремль
розпрощатися зі своїм богом річковим
курсом на економічно модернізацію
ct травня 1 негативний сплив